hello francine i'm ready for my fish
feeding now
all right bub
let's make fun of the duck
meet dee bradley baker he's a voice
actor and the man behind all kinds of
monsters and creatures in hollywood you
can watch this video we made about d a
while ago
but today he's gonna flex his vocal
talents and improvise a series of animal
sounds for us
ready yeah
go
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
there's lots to use inside the mouth and
i kind of use it along with the
resonance to do small things large
things threatening things friendly
things all kinds of things
[Music]
[Music]
pigs are always in demand
they're so much like us
that must look awful
all right now how about some birds
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
pretty bird
[Music]
[Music]
um
it's not just making the sound but it's
it's telling a story it's it's having
specific
things happening in the story it's kind
of like raw material for the animators
in the storyteller
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
excellent raccoon you make them sound
much cuter than they actually are yeah
yeah they're vicious little creatures
and smart sometimes it's just a monster
something just big and threatening and
monstrous
like a dragon getting hit by a sword
it can just this horrible screeching
sound that can be you know modified for
other kinds of different projects too
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
those are big dinosaurs
[Applause]
up
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sure it's lovely to look at too
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we can wrap it up
[Music]